les travaux de la route départementale 3
à la rivière saint-louis ont été
inaugurés ce mardi 4 octobre les travaux
situés à proximité du collège ruisseau
qui permettent une sécurisation du
cheminement des piétons et des élèves
grâce à la création de trottoirs de
places de parking de bus supplémentaires
et de zones de ralentissement
il s'agit pour nous collectivité
municipale de sécuriser les abords des
établissements scolaires
donc là vous êtes devant le collège du
ruisseau un peu plus loin vous avez
l'écologie waro et un peu plus loin de
ce sens vous avez d'école rien au monde
donc le département a déjà fait des
aménagements devant les écoles primaires
là il ya une sécurisation des abords du
collège du ruisseau et dans les deux ou
trois ans qui viennent il faudra relier
les aménagements qui nous est fait à
l'école jean waro et à l'école de rien
au monde on en montre le côté on a
réalisé un aménagement de sécurité
consiste à créer un trottoir
tout le long de entre la rue monseigneur
beaumont et
l'autre partie qui est déjà aménagé de
la côte et non du centre ville et on a
mis en place des dispositifs de
ralentissement et
au niveau des passages piétons et on a
accompagné tous les comment tous les ans
n'a fait des dispositifs aussi qu'ils
prennent en compte les pmr les personnes
à mobilité réduite à de nouveaux
aménagements de sécurité sont prévues
dans les prochaines années
les routes départementales du sud
représentent 50 % de la totalité de
celles de lille on a profité pour faire
le point avec le maire de la commune de
saint louis sur les projets routiers en
matière de routes départementales
en tout on en a peu à peu près 4
millions 700 mille euros de travaux
routiers sur la commune de saint de
saint-louis de 2015 à 2020 ce qui fait
que c'est un investissement conséquent
qui va dans le même sens sur l'ensemble
du département de la réunion on à
rebooster l'investissement cela les
routes départementales
les travaux de la rd 3 ont été réalisées
pour un montant total de 244 1000 euros
financés à hauteur de deux tiers par le
département